Homer Simpson isn't just a cartoon character.
He is, officially, one of the most influential
people of the modern era.
And he's also a pretty horrible human being.
For over 30 years, Homer's been abusing his
kids, lying to his wife, and causing all kinds
of mayhem as a result.
Hey, we love the guy, but the citizens of
Springfield probably lost their affection
for Homer Simpson long ago.
Especially after he did all these things.
The Maude mishap
Maude Flanders' demise via T-shirt cannon
is arguably the most shocking and callous
end in The Simpsons' long and storied history.
In "Alone Again, Natura-Diddily," the Flanders
and Simpsons families visit the local racetrack,
and Homer becomes obsessed with the cheerleaders'
T-shirt cannons.
Like, really obsessed.
First, he takes off his own shirt, trying
to get the cheerleaders' attention.
Next, he paints a bull's-eye on his chest.
Given Homer's size, that would be an easy
target — and the cheerleaders let a barrage
of T-shirts fly straight at him.
And then...
And that's the end of the line for poor Maude,
who didn't do anything wrong aside from crossing
paths with Homer Simpson one too many times.
Celebrity send-off
Technically, The Simpsons' annual Treehouse
of Horror episodes aren't canonical, which
gives the show's writers plenty of room to
stretch their creative muscles and go crazy.
But even by normal standards, the 2009 Treehouse
of Horror segment "How to Get Ahead in Gone-Vertising"
is extra-creepy.
The episode begins as a Mad Men parody but
quickly descends into a dark story in which
Homer hunts down superstars for money.
Homer starts by accidentally pushing Krusty
the Clown into a woodchipper.
And then he accepts money from advertising
executives to drown George Clooney in cement,
to strangle Prince with his own guitar, and
to brain Neil Armstrong with a golf club.
If only Homer's non-imaginary adventures weren't
also totally nuts...
Framing Marge
If you ask die-hard Simpsons fans to recommend
Homer's overall lowest moment, most of them
will probably point you to "Co-Dependent's
Day," a Season 15 episode that chronicles
Marge's struggle with alcoholism.
Homer, of course, has been a beer-guzzling
booze hound since the very beginning.
But in "Co-Dependent's Day," he enables Marge's
addiction.
First he takes her to Moe's, then they go
to an Oktoberfest celebration.
But the worst moment?
That comes when Homer, plastered from the
beer festival, tries to drive home and ends
up flipping the car.
When the police arrive, he frames Marge, who's
even more drunk than he is.
Marge goes to jail for driving under the influence,
and later checks into a rehab facility.
Homer, meanwhile, doesn't face a single consequence.
Now that's Homer's style of justice.
Vegas vows
As the saying goes, "What happens in Vegas,
stays in Vegas"— unless you're Homer Simpson.
In the episode "Viva Ned Flanders" Homer takes
Ned to Vegas for a night of crazy fun.
When they wake up from their booze-soaked
all-nighter, they're married to their waitresses
from the night before.
So they flee back to Springfield and forget
about their second wives...for about three
seasons.
In "Brawl in the Family," the two cocktail
waitresses track down their husbands.
After a judge refuses to annul Homer's marriage
to Amber, he takes matters into his own hands
and gets the woman drunk.
When Amber wakes up, she's married to Homer's
dad.
Horrified Amber takes off for Vegas as soon
as possible.
It's a funny way to turn the tables...until
you actually think about it for, like, two
seconds.
That's pretty creepy, Homer.
Kidney failure
In the Season 10 episode "Kidney Trouble,"
we all learn a valuable lesson: Homer's an
even bigger jerk than we thought.
In the first half of the episode, Homer causes
his dad Abe's kidneys to explode...because
he doesn't want to stop to let him use the
bathroom.
The doctor tells Abe he's a goner without
a transplant, and fortunately, Homer is an
exact match.
Less fortunately...well, it's Homer.
While Homer agrees to donate a kidney, he
takes off just before the surgery, leaving
his father alone and in pain.
Abe only gets the life-saving organ he needs
after Homer gets hit by a car and knocked
unconscious, giving Doctor Hibbert time to
steal Homer's kidney and complete the procedure.
Homer the henchman
Homer Simpson has had many, many jobs, but
he's only been good at one.
Unfortunately, that happened to be when he
was working for Hank Scorpio, a straight-up
supervillain.
This is Homer we're talking about, of course,
and he doesn't ever actually notice that Scorpio
is really a criminal mastermind.
He's too busy doing literally anything else
to realize that he's helping Scorpio conquer
the world.
"I'm having some trouble with the government."
"Awww… those jerks always walking over the
small businessman."
Even worse, Homer doesn't notice that his
family is absolutely miserable in Scorpio's
compound until it's too late.
Eventually, he comes around, and Scorpio lets
Homer return to Springfield — but not before
Scorpio's forces manage to conquer the East
Coast.
Good job, Homer.
They couldn't have done it without you.
Neighborly wish
Homer has gone out of his way to make Flanders'
life miserable plenty of times, but what he
does in the Season 3 episode "When Flanders
Failed" might take the cake.
At a backyard barbecue, Flanders announces
that he's quitting his job to open his own
store, the Leftorium.
So, naturally, Homer uses the powers of a
wishbone — to wish for Ned's business to
fail.
It works.
The Leftorium goes out of business, Ned's
house is repossessed, and the Flanderses are
forced to move into their car.
Sure, Homer eventually saves Ned from bankruptcy,
but Ned never would've been in trouble in
the first place if Homer hadn't been such
a jerk.
But that's Homer for ya!
"When he's least expecting it, bash his head
in with a chair."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!